tiger woods seriously injured in a car
crash what a day for you to be here to
guest host tamar brown oh
my god kevin i am in such shock what a
scary accident
yeah we have the latest on tiger because
he is lucky to be alive
we have a rollover with someone trapped
we are here on site at the horrific
crash scene tiger's vehicle flipped on
its side the front smashed in
airbags deployed and his golf bag laying
nearby
hit the curb hit a tree and there was
several
rollovers during that process sheriffs
tell e.t that the crash happened around
7
12 this morning tiger was the sole
occupant in the car
according to his agent tiger quote
suffered multiple
leg injuries tiger was taken directly
into surgery his injuries do not
appear to be life-threatening now it's
unclear what caused the crash
authorities are still investigating
the 45-year-old golf legend was in l.a
over the weekend for his annual
genesis invitational golf tournament you
can see the emblem
on the side of the vehicle debris here
at the scene indicates
that the vehicle may have flipped end
over end for nearly 500 feet
across the road obviously that indicates
they were going a greater
speed than than normal so what led up to
the crash
well the last few days have been busy
for tiger yesterday he had a shoot with
golf tv
and was photographed with celebs
including dwayne wade david spade and
jada pinkett smith
after his accident this morning jada
posted she was sending him prayers
at that golf tournament on sunday
tiger's appearance in the broadcast
booth had a lot of people concerned
his eyes were puffy and he said he was
feeling stiff after a fifth back surgery
have one more
mri scheduled still in the gym still
doing
the mundane stuff that you have to do
for
rehab last month tiger was the focus of
an hbo documentary which included a look
at this 2009
accident when he crashed his suv into a
tree
i am deeply sorry for my irresponsible
and selfish behavior the golf icon made
a staggering comeback
and was set to spend today continuing
that golf tv shoot